christian casadas joining us now in the
studio with a recap of some of the
biggest concerns christian well denise
it was quite interesting it was called
the pandemic stops with me and this
webinar was hosted by caesars
entertainment nevada minority health and
equity coalition and unlv school of
public health now this was a panel of
five experts including four doctors who
answered common questions about the
vaccine current stage of the pandemic
and they even touched on myths now these
community leaders are at the forefront
of covet 19 efforts right here in the
state and are working to achieve a
higher vaccination rate among minorities
dr erica marquez describes the biggest
challenge they face with a vaccine
hesitancy
i think one of our really hardest
challenges right now at this point in
the pandemic is the amount of
disinformation
and misinformation because it's almost
hard for us to keep up with that our
communities are so confused and with you
know you can go on to like dr c
mentioned you can go onto any social
media platform and there's folks sharing
so much information
the panel also focused on myths
surrounding the vaccine and what
pfizer's full fda approval actually
means all the parts that are in the back
seat have been used for years and tested
uh the idea that this vaccine was put
together too quickly well it was only
because we spent decades getting to the
point where we could put it together
quickly it's kind of like saying you
know i called the fire department and
they got here too quickly well yeah they
didn't have to build the trucks and hire
people it was all ready to go when there
was an emergency and that's what we did
with this vaccine it comes down to the
basic uh difference in the way we
approve vaccines so when there's an
emergency situation
there is a pressing need for that so we
want to use that vaccine sooner it
doesn't mean we skip steps
well the group also says statewide the
data is skewed because the majority of
our case numbers are coming from
southern nevada they say the delta
variant hit us here in the valley
earlier than most of the nation now the
panel reiterated the majority of the
people getting sick and dying are
unvaccinated and that these deaths are
completely preventable christian casadas
8 news now